Okay.
Welcome back to Gary’s Economics.
Today we are going to introduce
the first part of our online course.
Video number one, which is going to be What is Wealth.
Okay so I was at a conference
the other day, a conference about economics media,
and there was a guy who basically spoke about how
when people watch Jordan Peterson's videos,
they don't just watch his recent videos,
they go back to the beginning
and they watch it through.
Because what people want is an online course
where they can follow the subject through
so they understand it completely.
And he could do a MOOC. Massive Open Online Course.
And it got me thinking about this channel.
Basically,
this channel in my eyes is an educational channel
which is to teach
and educate ordinary people about economics,
basically pushing a specific narrative,
which is that living
standards are falling
because wealth inequality is increasing.
If you want to stop the decrease in living standards,
we need to stop the increase in wealth inequality.
But obviously I'm out here every week, making a video
every week.
You see a different video every week.
And I kind of worry that if somebody actually comes in
and they want to,
you know, understand exactly what we're doing here,
they just see like 100 different videos.
They don't know where to start.
And it becomes quite difficult
for people to educate themselves.
And, you know, we often get people asking us questions
which have been addressed in previous videos.
Like, for example, people say,
what do you mean when you say government gave hundreds
of billions of pounds to the rich during Covid?
The question we get asked tons recently is
can you really tax the rich?
If you tax them, won't they just leave?
We can asked questions about money,
questions about debt,
which are answered in previous videos,
and I suppose I could try
and go back to historical videos
and try and link something together.
But what I wanted to do was start creating
in amongst the other videos
we make,
a set of videos which are structured
and designed to be watched in order
such that anybody who comes to this channel
in a year's time or in two years
time, can go and watch basically this online course
that is really structured
and explains everything in a step by step fashion
about what
I'm saying and about my ideas
about wealth inequality in the economy,
so that you can understand things
in a really structured way, basically.
I wanted to add
basically a structured element to the channel
so that we keep the videos every Sunday.
But over time we start to build up
certain videos
which are designed to be watched in order,
and we put them together as an online course.
And today we are going to start that
and we are going to do video number one in the course.
And video number one is going to be called
What is Wealth, which is a very simple video
which is introducing the concept of wealth to people.
Because often economists don't talk much about wealth.
They talk about things like income.
They talk about things like jobs,
they talk about things like unemployment,
but they don't talk about things like wealth.
When I talk about inequality,
I'm always talking about wealth inequality
rather than income inequality.
And then in order to understand that,
you need to understand wealth.
So what is wealth?
First thing is wealth is different to income.
Now I think for most ordinary people
their financial situation
is basically about their income,
which is about what job they do.
When I was a kid,
I thought that if you wanted to be rich,
you got a job in a bank and you made,
you know, £100,000 a year.
If you can make £100,000 a year salary,
you're super rich.
And the difference between financial positions
of most ordinary people
is largely about what job do you do.
It's important to understand
there are a group of people
whose income does not come from their work.
Their income comes from wealth.
What is wealth?
Wealth is about ownership of things, of assets.
Now, the most
practical and close to ordinary
people's lives example of wealth is housing.
So some people own their own house they live in.
Some people don't own their own house
they live in and they rent their house.
Some people own their house with a massive mortgage.
Some people own the house
with a very small or no mortgage.
This is the most obvious example
of how some people have wealth and some people don't.
If you own your house
with no mortgage, you don't need to pay interest.
You don't need to pay rent.
You simply can live in that house essentially for free.
If you don't own a house, you will have to pay either
interest on a very large mortgage,
or you’ll have to pay rent.
So these houses exist the house that I live in exists.
Outside there's lots of houses and lots of flats.
Everything exists. Everything is owned by somebody.
That's the first thing.
If you don't own your own house, somebody else owns it.
Either through lending
you money for your mortgage or directly
they own it and you pay them rent.
So the first form of wealth, housing, it exists.
It's everything... it's everywhere.
Everything is owned by somebody.
I think this is quite visible.
People know that housing is important.
People know that either they own their own home
or they don't own their own home.
If they don't own their own
home, they have to pay rent.
I think what
people often fail to realise
is that there is much more wealth
other than housing in our society.
So I'm looking out here through this window.
I can see Whitechapel, there's a massive hospital right
there, that's Royal London Hospital,
that's worth an enormous amount of money.
It's owned by somebody. That's a form of wealth.
If I look out here back then to my right,
I can see Canary Wharf.
There's a bunch of enormous skyscrapers.
These skyscrapers are worth
an enormous amount of money.
They are owned by somebody. That is wealth.
There's a railway line out here
that is owned by somebody, that is wealth.
If I go just out here onto the main street,
that's Commercial Road,
there's lots of shops, there's lots of restaurants.
If I go over there
to Stratford, Westfield,
there's an enormous shopping centre.
In the centre of London there are tons of skyscrapers.
There are theatres.
There are pubs, bars, restaurants, shopping centres.
This is commercial wealth.
Now, what is interesting about commercial wealth
is ordinary people don't normally own it, right?
Ordinary people often struggling to own their own home.
They don't consider when they go to work in an office
or whether they go to shop in Tescos,
whether they go to a restaurant
that these commercial buildings are also owned as well.
Now, this is a massive part of wealth
and the fact that ordinary people
often don't own their own homes.
But more...
but
very often
don't own a significant chunk
of the commercial property
tells us another real fact about wealth,
which is that
property in many cases
is owned by ordinary people, by the middle class.
But commercial property is overwhelmingly owned
by the rich.
So what is wealth?
Largely in this country it's property,
residential property, but also commercial property.
Residential property is often owned by ordinary people.
Commercial property
is overwhelmingly owned by the rich.
One other big form of wealth
which is important to recognise is debt.
Now when you first hear that,
that might sound a little bit counterintuitive
because you think, okay, debt is not wealth,
debt is like a bad thing to have.
Debt is like negative wealth.
One thing you need to understand
is that debt always balances out.
If one person is in debt, another person is in credit.
So if you owe £400,000 on your mortgage,
that ultimately is owed to somebody.
One form of debt which gets an enormous amount of press
at the moment is government debt.
So the government has an enormous amount
of debt, it's equivalent to something like,
I haven't done the numbers recently,
but I think it's like £30 - 35,000
per person in the UK.
This enormous amount of government
debt is owed to somebody.
Debt often confuses slightly
the real ownership of wealth,
because the main form of wealth
which ordinary people own in this country,
the UK, it’s the same in
a lot of other countries, is their home,
but very often
they own their home
by using an enormous amount of debt.
So if, for example,
you live in London
and you own a home that costs £500,000,
which is a pretty
average cost for a home here in London,
you might have a mortgage of 400,
maybe even £450,000 on that house.
If you own a £500,000 house with a £400,000 mortgage,
basically you only own
20% of the wealth in your home,
and the other 80% is owned by
essentially whoever owns your mortgage.
Debt, like commercial property,
unlike residential property,
is another form of wealth
which is overwhelmingly owned by the rich.
Now, there are a lot of ways which...
there are lot of misunderstandings
about wealth, firstly, a comment
we often get is, no actually ordinary people own
their commercial property,
they own the debt to their pensions.
And to a tiny degree this is true.
If you have a pension, if you have some savings,
you will own some other people's debts.
If you own some stocks and shares,
you will own some small
share of the commercial property.
But really, it's a little bit of a red herring,
because overwhelmingly,
the amount on which ordinary people own
is tiny compared to the amount that the rich own.
Rich people have enormous funds, stock and share
portfolios, enormous pension
funds through which they own these things.
Ordinary people do own a little sliver
through their pension funds, but ordinary people own
only a very small percentage.
So what is wealth?
Wealth is not about income.
Wealth is not about your job.
Wealth is about who owns the physical
things in your country, the buildings, the property,
the natural resources.
You know, we didn't mention farmland.
The kind of wealth that is relevant
is different in different countries.
You know, if you're talking about
a country like Saudi Arabia,
like Qatar,
who owns the oil is an enormous part of the wealth.
You know, in a very agricultural country,
who owns the land is a big part of the wealth.
In this country, the UK, and it's similar
to a lot of
developed countries, it's largely about properties,
which is residential property, commercial property.
In some countries you might have a lot of factories.
You know, obviously China has a lot of factories.
Germany has more factories than we do.
But basically there is a lot of physical wealth
in the country.
Properties, buildings, natural resources, land,
productive things like the energy production capacity,
the windmills, the coal plants,
the oil plants, the nuclear plants.
There is all this physical wealth in the country.
Ordinary people
in most cases own only their own property.
And in many cases that's only through debt.
All of the rest of the wealth is owned by
essentially very wealthy people.
And this leads to cash flows.
The people who don't own the wealth
have to pay the people who do own the wealth
in order to use the wealth.
The most obvious example of
this is if you don't own your own home,
you will have to pay rent
to the person who does own your home.
If you do it in your home,
but using a massive mortgage,
you will have to pay interest
to the person who does own your mortgage.
And we spoke about the commercial property.
So this extends all through the commercial property.
So when you go shopping at Tesco,
part of the money that you pay
will go to the owner of that physical building
that your Tesco superstore is based in.
Some of it will go not just to
the farmer who maybe produced the food you buy,
but also to the landowner who owns the land.
Some of it will go to
the people who owned the energy resources that
transported the food to the supermarket.
When you pay your taxes, a big chunk of your tax
goes as interest payments
to the people who own the government debt.
So real wealth exists.
Debt exists.
Ordinary people have to pay the wealth owners
every single time. They basically spend any money.
Your rent, your mortgages, your food,
your bills, your taxes.
When you go to a restaurant,
when you go to a pub, when you go on holiday,
when you go to the supermarket,
a little chunk of every single thing
you spend is going to the wealth owners.
Which means there is a big net flow of cash
every day, every week, every month, every year
from ordinary people who don't own much wealth,
to very rich people who do own wealth.
These are basic concepts.
But it's important to understand,
because I think a lot of people
who are not rich don't
realise how much wealth there is,
and they don't realise they're paying to use it.
Mainly, they don't realise
how wealthy, wealthy people are.
And we're going to go in
in our next video in the online
course to how that affects you
and how that affects the economy.
Okay.
So that's video one of the online course,
What is Wealth.
We’re going to keep doing these videos
alongside the other videos.
We’re going to put them up on the YouTube
in a separate...
what do you call them, those things?
Yeah. In a separate playlist.
We're going to put them up
in a separate playlist on the YouTube,
so that over time
we build up a course that people can watch
from the ground up
and start to understand everything
in a really clear, simple way what we're doing.
We're not going to stop the other videos we're doing.
The more topical videos, the more salacious videos,
which I know you all love.
And the more,
yeah, educational videos
pushing for changing the tax system.
But hopefully this will give newcomers over the years
a place to really develop all of their understanding.
Okay. Thank you.